and so lock jets your party is over riot
games has announced a new system to fix
the problem of interlocking in valerian
and its cascading agent select so what
is this new system is it really needed
and will it make
ranked a better experience for everyone
[Music]
all right y'all before we get into the
video i gotta remind you as always hit
the like button the subscribe button and
to ring the notification bell if you
don't you're gonna have to play smokes
and be an omen mane so
have fun with that so
insta-locking if you have played
valorent i'm sure you have all
experienced this before insta-locking is
when you load into agent select and
immediately lock in the agent you want
to play not just clicking on it like
it's it's literally a race and if you're
not sure what i mean i will let shazam
demonstrate
[Music]
polish [ __ ] till i die
we got tommy bionicle73 smiley says 777.
god damn he's good and if you're like
liz why is that an issue i am so glad
you asked babes well it forces your
teammates to build a team composition
around you and what you wanted to play
they literally have to pick up the slack
they might have to play off roll or you
get the classic for duelist comp
basically you could be making things
more difficult for your team and the
game hasn't even started yet and it's
not just one person insta-locking i've
been in games or three or four people
just immediately lock in agents and i'm
forced to fill out the comp because i
made the mistake of thinking we would
talk to each other before the game
started if you're seeing a pattern of
frustration on my end you're right and
that's where interlocking becomes this
vicious cycle that infects others you be
common in slacker because you are so
sick of them so you can play what you
want to play this creates more
interlockers and the cycle repeats and
repeats and repeats until finally it's
the people with the best ssd who get to
play what they want so
how do we fix this problem well for riot
it's introducing a new system coming to
valerian and it's cascade agent select
in a recent dev stream we got a little
taste of what this will entail and i'll
let the devs explain we've we've talked
a lot we came up with um
we're calling it cascading agent pick we
i wanted to have it on the beginning
episode unfortunately we just we just
couldn't get out so it's uh hopefully
gonna land sometime in the episode uh
what cascade agent pick is is
the player will have they'll have like a
first second third fourth fifth pick
like you normally think of in like a
protected pick type sense um and the
first pick will have about 15 20 seconds
we haven't determined the exact time um
to pick their first agent and then if
they don't pick or if they pick an agent
it goes to the second person and so
you're not required to pick right away
if your first pick you can just like
wait a little bit um
so then it unlocks the third person to
pick the fourth person to pick the fifth
person pick so everyone it'll have a
trickle down or cascading effect of when
you can pick your agent now if that
sounds familiar it's a lot like another
riot game league of legends
for years the system in league ranked
has been for each team to pick one or
two champions at a time with no ability
to insta-lock cascade agent select isn't
exactly the same like you won't be
queuing up for a specific role but it's
pretty similar 15 to 20 seconds for each
person to pick an agent if they don't
pick one it passes on to the next person
so kind of like schoolyard dodgeball
except instead of sports it's bullets
and abilities on paper this stops the
problem of interlocking valorent but it
has the possibility of creating other
problems as well it is certainly a big
problem for one tricks if you're a
fourth or fifth pick in agent select and
someone takes the agent you are most
comfortable on that's not gonna be great
for you especially if you are a lower
level player or you're just flat out
brand new to the game it is sink or swim
it is difficult to know how exactly this
will pan out but we can look at similar
systems like league of legends one major
difference between the two games is the
amount of playable characters league of
legends has many many more champions
than ballerin has agents in league you
sign up for a role top bot jungle and
you're made to choose a champion from
there and you have a lot of options the
only correct option for support is uni
by the way with
157 champions this chances of someone
taking your champion especially when
you're all assigned different roles is
pretty slim invalorent though with only
18 agents and no assigned roles when you
enter a game
someone could definitely take your agent
especially if they're ones that are
widely fought over
reina
jet
reyna
jet it's also more likely you end up
with a disjointed team composition with
someone playing unfamiliar roles we
could go the overwatch route and
introduce rollock that means you would
queue to play a specific class of agent
sentinel doulas etc when you get into a
game there's less of a chance of someone
taking your agent because you'll most be
playing different roles but generally
speaking the overwatch community wasn't
too happy when it was introduced because
of how much diversity was taken away
from the gameplay i.e not running all
the same role because you feel like it
and it still doesn't fix the issue of
insta-locking when you take these
actions by limiting and restricting the
communities this much there will be
adverse reactions what it really boils
down to with cascade agent select is
that these solutions have been brought
forward because of the trend of
interlocking that we as a community have
created
well some of us even with everyone
taking turns the ability to play the
agent you want to play comes down to two
things one who you are playing with and
two
if they're gonna let you i've seen some
people on twitter suggesting that
instead of cascade agents luck there
should be a time period where people can
just talk to each other and are barred
from locking in i do truly appreciate
the sentiment of trying to make this
better but it doesn't fix the issue
people will have their cursor over who
they want to play if they're going to be
jerks about it we will still have the
problems that inslocking brings on our
hands so we have the good and the bad
when it comes to cascade agent select it
will fix the problem of insta-locking
but it'll force people to sit and watch
as their best agent is taken away from
them but what this all comes down to in
my opinion is that cascade agent select
is a solution to a legitimate but not
pressing problem in valorem the reality
is that interlocking isn't the biggest
baddest issue in the game it's something
that can be annoying and frustrating
absolutely but it's not something that
happens every single game and if it does
like it happened to me in all my games
last night it's still winnable if i were
to ask you what is the biggest issue in
balance right now
would you say to me it was insta-locking
in my opinion this is not a big enough
issue for ride to be implementing a
whole new system that may cause more
trouble than it's worth besides riot has
another monster they created on their
hands
[ __ ] [ __ ]
the gun is broken
this is okay
do they think
some people don't agree with my
assessment and say that it's a fine
solution to an unavoidable problem that
given the chance people will discuss
their team comp in this new system and
won't troll if they don't get their pick
and they have a point the issue isn't
the game mechanics it's the people that
decide to install troll etc and that
issue is everywhere it isn't just
invalid all in all here's how i see
cascade agent select going down once it
is implemented best case scenario you
load into a game people discuss their
team comps you know civil normal stuff
and it's fine worst case scenario people
don't listen and get upset when they
can't play the agent that they want to
play and they throw your promotion
matches it's going to be a game of
chance just like it already is for who
you end up in the lobby with the hope is
that a civil conversation might now
follow instead before where it was just
a insta-locking frenzy either way it is
not going to ruin your valor's
experience though it's going to change
things a little bit let me know your
thoughts on it and in sloggers come here
for a second
enjoy your time while it lasts
welcome to summoner's rift how was that
that was pretty good right
i was actually
i rate some real girl
there's a little bit more pause after
welcome she's like welcome
okay okay
welcome to summoner's rift
turret plating will soon fall